why chrissy teigen is apologizing  [Music]  the 31 year old model gave New York City  concert goers quite an eyeful Tuesday  night Wow  tell me why hubby John Legend brought  her on stage while he performed his 2006  hit slow dance before a crowd at Madison  Square Garden and she clearly enjoyed  every minute of it  shimmying and grinding up on her man  that is until her dance moves and boobs  became more than her splink II black  dress could handle legend quickly came  to the rescue  but not before the audience cut a quick  glimpse  Chrissy apologized for the slip-up and  the show went on the 31 year old mom is  of course very comfortable in her own  skin earlier this month she stripped  down on snapchat to show off her tan but  I truly just do the best I can do for my  body  [Music]  you